i recently moved house and found myself
with some new office space this is the
second bedroom in our property which is
let's say um
modest in size from this space i need to
do my job of mostly being a youtuber but
also streaming on twitch working on
commission for other people and now
unbelievably also being an author which
means that i need to use this space very
efficiently especially seeing as it also
has to double up as storage for some
other stuff so in this video i thought
i'd take you through the setup that i've
landed on after a bunch of iteration and
experimentation which i think is really
quite efficient and practical there's a
lot to talk about back here on this side
of the camera but i think we'll start
behind the camera where i do most of my
work looking this way there are several
big things you'll notice straight away
perhaps most obviously the acoustic
panels these do an amazing job of
killing the room noise in here before it
was quite echoey
[Music]
next to the panels though we do have the
most important thing in the room which
is of course jasmine i put this place
stand next to my desk so she can climb
up it and uh sit next to me and judge me
while i work which she does seem to
enjoy doing all of my work of course
takes place on the pc which uh the
actual computer itself is down here in
the corner it's quite difficult to film
sorry definitely why the cable
management looks bad it actually is good
you just it looks bad from this angle
all right this is a pc that my friend
built for me we actually built it
together on stream and uh here are the
specs i'm not really a hardware kind of
guy so there you go that's what the
computer is the desk itself is a basic
standing desk from ikea there's a little
handle just under here and the reason i
got this desk is that i need this
workstation to do a couple of different
things first of all it's obviously a
place where i can do work i can have for
example editing open on this screen and
then the script or research open on this
screen but with this pole mount here in
the middle of the desk that culminates
in a camera mount i can put the desk
into a couple of different
configurations normally of course i'd
have a dslr mounted on here but uh i'm
using that right now to film this video
so that's why um that's why it's not on
there with the desk in its lower
position and we sat down it's in
streaming mode so this is how i stream
on twitch which looks like this although
this is a dslr so obviously you can
change the view and you can go right the
way in hello i stream on twitch multiple
times a week by the way sometimes it's
science-based stuff such as going
through past papers in science and maths
but sometimes it's painting warhammer
sometimes it's playing games and once a
week it's the rp geek stream which is a
dungeons and dragons campaign played by
professional science communicators where
we one week we'll have our adventures
and the next week we talk about the
sites that we've run into that mode is
further facilitated by one of my
favorite pieces of kit this is a stream
deck which allows me to interact with my
streaming software so i can change uh
which scene i'm presenting to the
viewers but i can also do things like
play
music
[Music]
obviously i don't need to use that one
very often these panels behind the
computer are called nanoleaf panels and
i use them for my principal light when
i'm streaming the reason i use them is
because they're completely customizable
so you can turn them on and off at the
touch of a button or if you want you
could change them to be different colors
or you know you can even make them react
to sound however if i unhook the handle
and start raising the desk up then i can
put the desk into filming mode and this
is what it looks like in filming mode
okay well i cheated slightly there's a
hair light i've added up here and
there's a big key light over here but
you get the idea this is how i film my
videos with the camera in exactly the
same position as when i'm streaming just
with the desk elevated this is trying to
eliminate any barriers between making
content in one form or the other because
i stream and film several times a week
the difference being that you're now at
eye level which means you have a proper
view of
the set my personal hypothesis is that
audience members subconsciously view
youtubers as manifestations or avatars
of a particular
interest or a particular subject so when
i was constructing the set i wanted it
to be practical and somewhere that i
could actually store stuff but also to
represent some of those interests some
of those subjects so you have plenty of
books plenty of science books in
particular you also have science in
other ways like the use of energy and
the light bulb and i guess the globe
it's a bit on the nose there's
references to my online community in the
form of claude the capybara and of
course some warhammer in fact almost all
of the bottom 40 the bottom two tiers of
the set is actually off camera and just
storage to do with my hobby and painting
warhammer every kind of thing here from
basing materials to paints there's a
drawer here which is just for oil paints
and inks this one is for my airbrushing
stuff just to try and keep it organized
the black cladding behind the set isn't
painted on because we live in a rental
property and this is actually one of
pixel girl's ideas black fabric that you
use normally in gardens to prevent weeds
from sprouting up through the soil two
layers of that hung up on some command
strip hooks and jobs are good and it
even gives a really nice texture i think
the lights illuminating the backdrop are
philips hue lights which means they're
also controllable via an app completely
customizable and i like to vary the
backdrop in different videos or even in
one video if there's lots of different
sections changing the background color
to represent the different sections as i
mentioned earlier the set is intended to
be aesthetic but also practical so
whilst it's full of books these are
books that i actively refer to quite
regularly somewhat disappointingly
there's also a bunch of fake books which
i've put in them that very few people
seem to have noticed they're very
roughly categorized by sections
including one section that is literally
just my two read next pile and
suppressingly large on average i'd say i
take something from this set and use it
once or twice a day so it's constantly
in use it's actually worked out really
nicely there's also some other stuff
down here like i think my youtube
plaques here and my degrees and there's
other stuff like some spare notebooks
but it's mostly to do with painting
stuff that has been painted goes here in
the minish cabinet in the corner this is
just a debt off from ikea with some led
strips i won't spend much more time on
this in the video because i know not
everyone's interested but if you would
like to see some close-ups of these
models then you can check out 50 shades
of space wolfgray on instagram i also
have a youtube channel which simon clark
errata where i upload painting recaps
and you can see some close-ups of for
example the hawaiian orcs my high fleet
nostromo tyranids my original chapter
space marines and also a couple of other
things like for example this mandalorian
haven't loaded there for a while because
i hadn't had much time to paint but
that's changed now because i've finished
the book and i can actually get my
evenings back that then just leaves this
one wall which you don't see when i'm
streaming or making videos and this is
pretty much just storage it's where i
keep camera equipment audio equipment
and also lots of gubbins which i meant
to have found a new home for by now but
in the house move they've just sort of
accumulated where they are there's also
bins full of stuff here which i don't
use very frequently like particular
camera mounts and charges and things
like that i do then have these two
prints up on the walls this is a poster
that i actually made along with the
amazing artist lizzy fiekovsky basically
no one's bought one but you can buy one
if you want it's all about the different
layers and structure of the atmosphere
and then this is a print by mark rothko
most of rothko stuff i find quite
depressing and blue literally whereas
this is obviously very energetic and
bright and happy and i like that and i
like how it fits in with the rest of his
work so that's why it's on the wall in a
way all the physical stuff in this
office is really supplementary to the
computer and the data that's on it
that's fundamentally what my job is
based on over the past decade or so i've
generated about 10 terabytes worth of
data which is partly stored on the
computer's hard disk but then i also
have an external hard drive and some of
it's obviously in the cloud in the past
i've lost an entire hard drive's worth
of data because i plugged in the wrong
external power source and
just like that i'd lost years of
memories so for the past several years
just as i have home insurance for the
contents of this room in case of fire or
burglary i also have insurance for my
data from a company called backblaze
i've been a happy paying customer of
theirs for years and so when they
offered to sponsor a video it was an
easy yes with batblaze you can upload as
much of your data as you want and it can
be documents photos videos whatever and
upload it to their servers then in case
your data is lost or destroyed on your
local disk they can send you your data
that can be a download to your new
device or they can send you a hard drive
with your data on it and considering
that i have approximately 10 terabytes
of data with them i think i'd probably
go for the hard drive batblaze is
recommended pretty much everywhere
they've got tons of satisfied customers
they've restored over 50 billion files
and in all the years that i've used them
i have nothing to say but good things if
you'd like to check them out then you
can get a 15 day free trial at
batblaze.com
simon clark which allows you to test out
their service and also supports this
channel if you do want to carry on after
that trial then it's just seven dollars
a month which i think is an absolute
bargain considering that we pay for home
insurance and car insurance your data is
arguably even more important and
considering that you can upload as much
data as you want i think seven dollars a
month is a very fair price for peace of
mind that's batblaze.com forward slash
simon clark if you want to give them a
try thank you to blackblaze for
sponsoring this video but also for
keeping me a happy customer for the past
several years i hope you'll agree that
this setup i've landed on is really
quite practical it allows me to stream
and make videos and work at the desk and
research and paint incredibly easily
that said if you have any thoughts on
the setup or perhaps some ideas about
how to improve it then do let me know
down there in the comments i'd be really
interested to get your thoughts if you'd
like to see some other videos from me
then do check out the recommended
viewing here and that just leads me to
say thank you for watching i hope you
enjoyed it if you did please do pop the
video a like and i'll see you in the
next video